que faites-vous vous n'êtes pas un ingénieur
vous n'êtes pas un designer
vous ne pouvez pas mettre un marteau sur un clou j'ai construit
le circuit imprimé l'interface
graphique a été volée
alors comment se fait-il que dix fois par jour je lis
Steve Jobs comme  génie que faites-vous les
musiciens jouent leurs instruments je joue de
l'orchestre j'entends que tu as été pire
que d'habitude ce matin je ne pensais pas
que
c'était possible  cela ne peut pas être résolu en
quelques secondes treize demi-secondes vous aviez
trois semaines l'univers a été créé dans
le tiers de ce temps eh bien un jour
vous devrez nous dire comment vous l'avez fait
je vous supplie de gérer les
attentes là-bas vous voyez  comment cela vous
rappelle un visage amical c'est chaleureux et c'est
ludique et invitant et il faut dire
bonjour si vous continuez à vous aliéner les gens
sans raison il n'y aura plus personne
pour dire bonjour à votre action Apple
valait 441 millions de dollars  eh bien votre
fille et sa mère sont sur l'aide sociale,
elle n'est pas ma  ma fille
tu dois pouvoir voir qu'elle
te ressemble tu donnes des
instructions contradictoires tu es insubordonnée tu
rends les gens malheureux et même si
c'était vrai ça ne me semble pas si diabolique
nous avons parlé au prévôt des incendies dans le
gestionnaire d'immeuble ils vont entrer
et dire à tout le monde de partir si un incendie
provoque une ruée vers les sorties non signalées
ça en aura valu la peine pour ceux
qui ont survécu à la police du port tu n'es
plus nécessaire à cette compagnie
j'ai envoyé Mirage  et a inventé l'avenir
parce que les artistes dirigent et les hacks demandent à
main levée tu vas faire n'importe quoi
tu es ridicule